hi there it's Kevin van ORD standing in
for reviewer Dan Starkey to tell you
about super smash brothers we use each
time you select a new character and
Super Smash Brothers Wii U it's like
being given a brand new tool box you
won't know how to use every move
immediately but every one of them has a
purpose your role is to learn when and
where to use each skill you have to
maintain your own balance and be
constantly ready to punish a mistake and
at every step in the process you have
some degree of control
one of Smash Brothers we use many
wonders is how it is open to the
inexperienced but gives advanced players
the opportunity to spread their wings
the game is packed with dozens of
challenges training modes and mini-games
these modes aren't pointless additions
event matches and challenges have you
trying new approaches with characters
you aren't used to often to help you
learn something you may never have
discovered otherwise ledge guarding a
staple and previous smash games has been
completely removed this pushes a lot of
the combat off the stage and requires
stronger aerial play while most moves
also knock foes farther than they used
to each character generally only has two
or three solid killing moves that means
that clean knockouts have a much higher
skill for which in turn translates into
a distinct cut between high-level and
low-level players
these changes benefit everyone casual
players are able to survive much longer
than they may be used to making sure
that they aren't left out of the game
entirely professionals still have the
skillset necessary to dominate the less
experienced but cheap kills aren't
common it helps satisfy every kind of
fan without diminishing the experience
for any one group if you have an amiibo
then you've got yet another option to
practice amiibos work like AI opponents
that you can customize a bit allegedly
they can also learn and adapt to better
handle other people's play styles and
that actually seems to be the case
expect a challenge when facing max level
amiibo figures and should you change
tactics the amiibo really does respond
perhaps by baiting you to attack or by
spamming ranged attacks to try and
create an opening if you don't have
friends around and ever get sick of the
single-player options
amiibos are great additions even if they
are a little pricey for most players the
goal of all this training is to test
your skills against friends and that's
where smash brothers for Wii U really
excels turning item drops up to high in
cramming eight players into a relatively
small space is a very special kind of
unbridled lunacy
you can still play standard matches with
four combatants and that's as great as
it's always been there are quite a few
new stages in which to slug it out and
more than enough to provide a good
variety many levels change dramatically
over time and force you to keep up with
the shift and as long as you're not
looking for serious competition it's
always hilarious to watch unwitting
folks fall because they weren't
expecting the bottom of the level to
suddenly drop away and if the great
diversity of stages isn't enough for you
you can use the Wii U gamepad to create
your own levels there are too many
restrictions on size and there aren't a
lot of tools available but drawing
ridiculous levels with a touch pad more
than makes up for it sadly you can't
have eight player matches on custom
stages online multiplayer is the game's
bigger problem the five-second countdown
that marks the conclusion
timed match could take more than a
minute where the entire match may be so
laggy is to be unplayable online play is
extremely hit or miss and while the hits
are sublime
the misses are absolutely maddening
thankfully local play is absolutely
incredible
between the masterpiece collections
which are short demos of the classic
games that inspired Smash Brothers many
fighters and stages and the deep
character customization for fine-tuning
your fighters to suit your play style to
extensive screen shot editing tools
there's just so much to do with the Wii
U release Smash Brothers has fully
realized its goals there's something
here for nearly everyone from young to
old casual the hardcore presented almost
without compromise the game invites
everyone to join its undiluted joyous
celebration of the broad community that
Nintendo has built over the past 40
years
you